hello next week the
recently elected MEPs will
meet for the first time in
strasbourg in plenary session the
new key positions in the
european parliament will then be allocated on tuesday
morning priority will be given to the
president who will succeed martin schulz
is this going to be for five years  or
only for half of the
legislature
at noon the MEPs will vote
one or more rounds during the
week it may be necessary
once the president is elected it will be the
turn of the vice presidents of parliament
to be appointed by their colleagues
another great moment of the week the
greeks will pass the torch of the
presidency of the european union to the
italians who will be hit hard by the crisis
athens has all the same managed to complete
crucial files such as the
banking union which the italians will in turn do
the  Prime Minister
Matteo Renzi will present the priorities
for the next six months, namely the
relaunch of  growth and job creation
Wednesday afternoon the casting of
parliament continues 1 of the votes of the day
will relate to the number of deputies per
parliamentary committee remember that
the deputies work in small
groups the committees according to their
specialization budget environment
economy health etc but  who will be a member
of some missions who will be the
presidents the proposal negotiated between
the group presidents will be put to the
vote on Thursday and in the corridors of
parliament throughout the week the
discussions will certainly
revolve around the future president of the
european commission one week
exciting looms